near zero and values of theta near one are in fact close together.
So for example, if theta is equal to 0.99 and we approximate this value
of theta by the value zero,
then that's a pretty good approximation in the sense that it's
within one of our hundred of the actual value, when
we wrap around the circle
and go back to zero when we get to one.
The term modular one is sometimes used to describe the situation, where we're essentially
equating theta equals one with theta equals zero.
The point is that we really care about the location of the point
E to the two pi I theta on the unit circle,
and thinking about this
way of approximating theta makes sense when we have that aim in mind.
The problem statement itself,
as it appears on the screen, isn't specific about how good the approximation to theta needs to be,
but that's something that we can fine tune depending upon our needs.
In some situations we might be satisfied with a low precision
approximation to theta, and in other situations we might demand
a very high precision approximation, and the problem statement itself
can be refined accordingly.
Next we'll see how we can solve
the phase estimation problem with a quantum computer and
we'll start with a warmup.
This won't be our final
solution to the problem.
What we'll do is to make use of the phase kickback phenomenon to try to learn something
about the eigenvalue corresponding to a given eigenvector.
Recall that in the
phase estimation problem we're given the description
of a unitary quantum circuit for some operation U,
and what we do first is to
use this circuit description to create a new circuit that implements a controlled U operation like
is pictured on the screen.
This is pretty simple to do. What we can do is to add a control Qubit, which is pictured on
the top in this diagram
and use this new control
Qubit as a control for every single gate that
appears in our circuit.
So all of the gates are applied if this control Qubit is set to one, and none of them is applied if the control Qubit is set to zero,
That means that we're going
to need a controlled version of every gate that
appears in the circuit U, but we don't need to think
about these new controlled gates
as single gates if we don't want to. They could be implemented
as small circuits made out of gates from whatever gates set
we've chosen to use. And once we have a
controlled version of U, we can consider running this circuit,
where we first put the control Qubit into a superposition of zero and one, apply the controlled U gate to the eigenvector side that we're given,
and then apply a Hadamard gate
to the control and measure.
We'll see why it makes sense to do this as we go through the analysis, but even before we get to the details, we can immediately see a similarity
with Deutsche's algorithm for instance, where we're applying a
couple of Hadamard gates and measuring as a way
of effectively probing
what it is that some given
operation is doing here.
It's a controlled unitary
rather than a query gate, but there are very similar ideas at play.
So let's see what the circuit does.
The initial state is the eigenvector psi, tensored with the zero
state for the control Qubit,
applying the first Hadamard gate transforms the state of the
top Qubit to a plus state and we can expand the entire
state as is shown right here.
We then apply the controlled U operation and what that does is to apply U to psi when the control Qubit is set to one,
but not when it's set to zero. So we get the state pi two
that's written on the screen.
We can simplify the state
using the fact that psi is an eigenvector of U with eigenvalue e to the two pi I theta.
So we get that eigenvalue multiplying the second
term, but not the first.
And we can simplify using the bilinearity
of the tensor product.
So what we have here is the
phase kickback phenomenon, but this time it's happening for some arbitrary eigenvector psi of some arbitrary unitary operation U,
s opposed to a not operation being applied to a minus
state more specifically.
So that's the state after the controlled U operation is applied.
By the way, it's worth
taking a moment to notice that the state of the bottom end Qubits is still the eigenvector psi.
Which is great because that
gives us the opportunity to use it again if we choose.
Then the second Hadamard gate is performed and here is the state that we get.
And I haven't shown all the
details of the derivation here, but if you apply the
Hadamard gate and simplify, this is what you should get.
So that's the state just
prior to the measurement.
So we can focus on this state to see what we can learn
about theta by measuring.
And if we measure the top
Qubit or the rightmost Qubit, these are the probabilities that we get for the two outcomes.
And here have used a
couple of basic formulas that relate sins and cosines
to complex exponentials to express these probabilities
in terms of sins and cosines.
Specifically, the probability to get zero is the cosine squared of pi times theta and the probability to get one